we'll be searching high and low on the
deck and down below but it's a cryin
shame yeah Jenny Dana gets to show off
his body for the comedy Hail Caesar and
he impressed his co-star George Clooney
but what about Channing's own little
two-year-old daughter our Carly steals
at Dallas buzz boys just this morning
you said that Everly cried when you were
singing to her actually yeah pretty much
she's a guy stop just don't do that does
it make you stop saying or you just oh
no that's a proud father go harder
well little Everly made up EF an but we
think Channing's got some chops and some
smooth Gene Kelly mood thanks to wife
Jenna Dewan Tatum and a lot of rehearsal
I also read that I Jenna helped you out
with that a little bit she did she was
actually really really gracious about
that because she's an amazing tap like
she's been doing she was part about
eight Jenna loaned him the sailor suit
which I thought was nice yeah I see I
see her tight ready I wouldn't I would
never do that
busted I really like your tap dancing
skills more than your singing skills she
likes the tap dances we got a little
time dancing shoes and she just likes to
like make noise all day can't get him
off of her she falls down all the time
but cuz they like nice good